thank you Mr Speaker and today all
Internationals women's day we celebrate
the successes of women in our society
they've say coaching forces through our
world leading modern slavery framework
which protects women from exploitation
Mr Speaker in the last decade this
government has introduced five plans to
tackle Illinois illegal immigration five
utter failures
problem just gets worse with every new
gimmick the Home Secretary says the
public are sick of tough talk and
inadequate action does he agree with her
assessment of this government's record
well Mr Mr Speaker what the honorable
gentleman fails to recognize that there
is a global migration problem we are not
alone in facing these challenges and it
is precisely because it is precisely
because that across Europe the numbers
escalating to the extent they are we
have brought forward new plans because
we are determined Mr Speaker to ensure
that this remains a compassionate and
generous country that that is done
fairly and legally
that's why we will break the criminal
gangs Mr Speaker we've announced new
agreements with Albania and France
tougher tougher immigration enforcement
and now new legislation that makes it
clear that if you come here illegally
you will be detained and swiftly removed
but Mr Speaker what we haven't heard is
The Honorable gentleman's plan we know
what it is it's open door immigration
and unlimited Asylum whilst teammate be
on the side of the people Smugglers
we're on the side of the British people
Mr Speaker if he was serious about
stopping the boat he'd actually steal
our plan on stopping the boat smash the
gangs sort out the returns and clean up
the utter mess Mr Speaker
I'm good to hear this and nobody's going
to I wonder if I were you but
I think we're good enough I want to hear
the questions and the answers and they
won't be interrupted Mr Speaker nobody
on this side of the house wants open
borders on that side they've lost
control of the body
now please promise the country he's
promised the country that this bill will
stop all Small Boat Crossings now ifs no
buts sounds like more talk so in the
interest of adequate action when will he
achieve that
oh Mr Speaker we we Mr Speaker we'll be
implementing this man as soon as we can
pause it through Parliament so I look
forward to the honorable gentleman's
support but the reality is Mr Speaker on
this issue The Honorable gentleman has
been on the wrong side of this stuff
prime minister Mr Stafford if you don't
want to hear him you can go and have a
good cup of tea nice and strong guys
this way but I will here in prime
minister
Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman has
been on the wrong side of this issue his
entire career
describe all immigration law as racist
he said it was a mistake to control
immigration
and he has never ever voted for tougher
Asylum laws
it's clear Mr Speaker while he's in
Hawke to the open border activists we're
on the side of the British people
Mr Speaker when I was in charge of
prosecutions I extradated countless
rapists and and the convict the
conviction rate for people smuggling was
twice what it is today
I voted against his legislation last
time because I said it wouldn't work
since it became law the numbers have
gone up he's proved me right he should
be apologizing not gloating
the Prime Minister says they will detain
people who aren't eligible to claim
Asylum here and then return them well
they already tried that under the last
legislation last year 18 000 people were
deemed ineligible to apply for Asylum
that's the easy bit the talk but as for
the action prime minister how many of
them have actually been returned this to
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker as as a result as
a result of the plans we brought forward
we have almost doubled the number of
people returned this year but he talked
about he talked about laws he talked
about uh
I think the Plumb bench needs to be a
little quieter because I want to hear
you joining in I'm going to I'm a
constituents want to hear the importance
of premises questions but the questions
for the answers sure where we could
Stitcher is the respect the Jew come on
please Mr Speaker he asked he asked he
asked about rest he asked about our laws
actually when I was in Dover yesterday
talking to our law enforcement officials
what do they tell me precisely because
of the law that the conservative
government passed last year they have
now been able to arrest more than double
the number of people they did before
397 in the last six months but stopping
the boats Mr Speaker stopping the boats
is not just my priority it is the
people's priority but his position his
position on this is clear he wanted to
in his words scrap the Rwanda deal he
voted against measures to deport foreign
criminals Mr Speaker and he even argued
against deportation flights well and we
know why because on this matter he
talked about his legal background he's
just another Lefty lawyer standing in
our way
I know you're welcome
we'll continue when you keep shouting it
prolongs and some of you are trying to
catch my eye when you're disappointed I
don't want any complaints let's get
through these questions so we might get
some Mike Benson Mr Speaker all that
nonsense because he doesn't want to
answer the question because he knows
what the answer is the number is 21. I
thought it was a man of ditto 21 21
people out of the 18
000 of what happens to the rest they sit
in hotels and digs for months on end of
the taxpayers expense last year he
promised to end the hotel fast that's
the talk but because of his mess there
are thousands of people who can't claim
Asylum and can't be returned so where
does he actually think they're going to
end up
Mr Speaker he talks about the pressure
on our Asylum system all right so
so
we've actually got a clear plan to stop
people coming here in the first place Mr
Speaker let he labor labor have
absolutely no plan on this issue because
they simply don't want to tackle the
problem
we introduced we introduced tougher
sentences for people Smugglers they
opposed it we signed a deal with Rwanda
they opposed it we are deporting foreign
offenders as we speak they oppose it
I'm going to say to the member from Hull
save that good voice for the rugby match
you might be able to join Mr Staffing
over that strong cup of tea prime
minister
Mr Speaker in fact the opposed every
single step of what we've done to try
and stop this problem in fact his only
his only contribution to this debate
well we know what it is in in words what
did he say we will defend free movement
that's the labor party for you Mr
Speaker
Mr Speaker he stood there last year
saying exactly the same thing we said it
wouldn't work they passed the law the
numbers went up they absolutely deluded
he can't say where they'll return people
because they spent 140 million on Rwanda
and it doesn't work they can't say how
they'll return people because this bill
doesn't come with a single new return
agreement and they can't say when
they'll fix the mess because it's more
talk more gimmicks more promises to be
broken now a few months ago I put to him
that I'll
been processed he stood there and said
that's unacceptable
what's the number down
because there were
as a result as a result of what we've
done there are now 6 000 fewer people in
the case load of Asylum backlog where
hiring more caseworkers were increasing
their productivity and again he's
mistaken when it comes to returns Mr
Speaker because we do have returns
agreements with India with Pakistan with
Serbia with Nigeria and crucially now
with Albania where we are returning
hundreds of people Mr Speaker but look
our position on this is clear if you
arrive here illegally you will not be
able to claim Asylum here you will not
be able to access the modern slavery
system and you will not be able to make
spurious human rights claims that is the
right thing to do but he's simply he's
going on and on about process hiding
behind process because he doesn't want
to confront the substance we are the
party of fairness and he represents the
party of free movement
okay
I thought you were supposed to be the
man of detail he's gone to all Outlets
to avoid the detail he knows the answer
the question less than one percent for
those arrived by boats have been
processed it shakes his head it's the
government's own statistic on his watch
on his watch processing of those boat
cases has gone from unacceptable in his
words to almost non-existence and
doesn't that tell you everything you
need to know after 13 years Small Boat
Crossings higher than ever claims
unprocessed the taxpayer paying for
hotel rooms criminal gangs running all
the way laughing to the bank and an
asylum sister utterly broken on his
watch this is their fifth prime minister
their sixth immigration plan their
seventh Home Secretary and after all
this time all they offer is the same old
gimmicks and empty promises I don't
agree with the homesick film very much
but when she says that the Tories are
all talk and no action she's spot on
isn't she
Mr Speaker
foreign
Mr Speaker illegal immigration
enforcement up the amount of people
processing claims up the backlog is down
the number of returns agreements is up
new new hundreds of people returned to
Albania and now new laws to detain and
deter illegal migrants it's clear what
we stand for Mr Pica we're doing what's
right we're acting with compassion we
are acting with fairness and we are
acting to respect the laws and borders
of our country we are delivering what we
said and it's Crystal Clear listening to
this Mr Speaker it's going to be the
conservatives and only the conservatives
that stop the boat